this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
excited what up dog I'm excited too we
got Bill Bellamy Bill's been famous how
long he's been famous for 50 years good
a good quarter of a century now what I
tell you in the bathroom he he
he's the one who came up with the term
booty call yes you're welcome dude
you're welcome all you youngsters out
there using that term booty call you owe
our boy Bill you're welcome some money
you may die um I uh by the way I'm gonna
be at the Blue Room which you've been to
in Springfield
[Music]
I'm telling you yeah
he might be 94. you like is that true
yeah I promise but he's he's great I
can't wait old school old-timey comic
comes with the one-liners I'm excited
it's bad like you don't have them open
for you and I'm in Phoenix but hopefully
not by dude it's gonna be August 11th
two shows it's a Friday two shows August
11th at stand up live Phoenix baby and
then after Phoenix I go to uh I know I'm
in Omaha I'm in Kansas City
let's see when is that so Phoenix August
11th Omaha Nebraska one night only
August 16th Kansas City Missouri one not
only August 17th Liberty Township Ohio's
August 30th then I end that trip in
Columbus Ohio shout out to the Buckeyes
Columbus Ohio August 31st then Spokane
with my favorites in September 21st to
the 23rd the new Iron skank Fest baby
it's going good skank Fest those skank
effects I'm drinking my magic mind here
you know you love that stuff yeah well
my my wife is panicking because we ran
out of it so this makes my coffee last
longer this this is this gives me such a
clean High I love it well I told you our
boy who started who's basically the the
Elon Musk of that world he's a freaking
genius I told you I ran into him uh a
while ago at the Halloween uh pumpkin
night Jack's night yep and you know he
started me talk about Adderall and
coffee how much coffee and espresso
drink he's like dude I'm telling you
with magic mine you you can wean off the
coffee you'll forget about the Adderall
you know I just thought it was like a
pitch no it's a line it's a Five Hour
Energy and you know I know you know how
why he started this because he had a
heart attack but you but you know like
you couldn't drink the amount of
Adderall and coffee I was taking like it
wasn't going to end well I thought he's
just pitching it and think about it I
stopped taking out her what four months
ago yeah I haven't touched it no I take
that so now I'm down to one coffee a day
I take a coffee in the morning take it
with this yeah same time down that I
take my coffee you need one cup
of coffee all of it dude I know yeah I
don't want coffee I don't have the
headache well because you don't get you
don't feel jittery you feel uh you feel
energized and it's good I like the way
it tastes yeah but it's it's like a
natural adaptogens it's got matcha it's
got I don't even know it's Health in a
bottle dude in a little tiny clear
bottle and then you read that tell me if
you can read that because now I feel bad
if you can yeah which one which one it's
adapter it says take it alongside your
morning caffeine benefits uh build with
daily use best serve chill uh I'm old
man Shake breathe drink baby you can
read that yeah I'm young man
says magic mind matcha boost your energy
adaptogens helps you relax nootropics
keeps you focused Agave for that sweet
sweet little happy vibe
do more stress less I I like mine
refrigerated I have to be refrigerated
they don't have to be it's not gonna go
bad but it has to be refused yeah yeah
dude I don't take Adderall one coffee a
day and here's here's a great you know
me I'm a coffee connoisseur yeah I'm
gonna drink a full cup anymore dude you
know a half a cup it's a waste of coffee
it does something I I there's something
in it that makes your caffeine somehow
like the release lasts longer I think
what are the fights we're doing the
fight companion with Rogue but what are
the fights it's August 5th um but the
Jake Paul fight no well that's Jake Paul
Nadia's fight but also we're doing it
for the Corey sanderhagen fight but his
opponent just pulled out do you know
that chin oh boy
so his opponent uh never mind off just
pulled out he's injured so they've got
to find a late replacement for him that
guy's a beast
Umar they say he's
he's the real deal no no one wants to
fight him but Corey's just showing he's
gangster so he's gonna do it yeah but
the good thing is we also have induction
uh jacobi's on there too my boy Billy
quintillo's on there OSP Jessica and
Josh and then Tatiana Suarez who I think
is going to be the strawweight champion
any day now she's back I could she's
fantastic
said Niger madoff's on there he's a
beast but um the good thing is even
we're doing the command for this we can
just also do it for the Nate Diaz and
Jake Paul fight you know Nate Diaz A
plus 240. that's interesting I don't
know it's tough to call because well
Jake is Big so his name is bigger no but
Nate Jake is bigger and much younger
and uh Nate's taller but Jake's heavier
younger more explosive yeah don't have
technique though Jake doesn't no like me
some fight Tommy fury like each
now I you know there's a reason why
Jake's uh you know a favorite but when I
saw the sparring footage of Nate you
people kind of hate on it I looked at
him I give you a Nate fan man you
shouldn't frown upon that like he was
going against 31 boxer pressuring him I
didn't see it yeah he's pressuring him
he's like he's doing a good job my my
whole thing with like if Nate doesn't
come fully prepared like he's fighting
Khan or something like that if he just
thinks it's a YouTuber he'll get knocked
out right but if Nate takes this serious
I get a five Nate's a beast dude he
doesn't get tired and he's got a lot of
volume
so it'll be interesting to see you just
you know he doesn't knock guys out you
know I don't think he can come at him
with his hands down but he's going to be
boxing yeah
yeah he won't come out he won't right no
not unboxing okay yeah yeah but it's
gonna get weird because if he gets out
of the first I'd say if Jake doesn't get
done the first two rounds three rounds
it's gonna get dicey yeah and then I I
would I'd take Nate all day if he does
if you can't fish him in the first I'll
say to me for three rounds really Nate's
gonna win that fight wow he's a plus 240
dog man
I'm excited I'm just curious what's
gonna happen if Jake beats him like one
of them they say is gonna say that she's
running for the line so Woodley's faking
it been asking is faking it this guy's
fake such a good fight for NATO because
if he does beat Jake it just it makes
him even the people gonna be rooting for
him I mean it makes well everyone's
rooting for a Nate no matter what even
with all his losses but so that's
besides the point the point is is if if
Nate were to lose Tom it's just like
Nate represents like fighting like
Street anybody anytime then you lose to
this YouTuber and people like oh like
his wins are fake like where what are
you guys going to say that I think Jake
Paul has proven that he's serious though
he's getting in there with real with you
know no one cares about that though yeah
the naysayers like oh it's all set up
it's fake but it's not fake I mean he's
clearly not Von Anderson Silva man and
you know beat him dude that's a great he
looked the best in that fight I don't
know what was going on with that Fury
Fury's Fury's been schooled by his
family he's got real coaches
so does Anderson and way bigger fights
like I think but here's a big where is
your boxer no there's just an age yeah
you're right he is you're right oh age
is everything it just is yeah you're
right I'm excited you don't feel it when
you're when you're older I agree oh our
boy Bill's here bill is here Bill
Bellamy all right let's uh enjoy Bill
Bellamy everybody maybe let's take a
little break I'll I'll be in Phoenix not
taking a break August 11th at stand up
live I'm all over Daddy but it's never
easy dude and you're in uh Springfield
Missouri Springfield Missouri and then
the uh Ontario Improv here in the
heartland of Los Angeles and the Inland
Empire yep uh you know what talk to me
about the fact that sometimes if I get
hurt can I give you some fast food on
some AdSense dude did you know that 35
of all fatal accidents occur between 6
p.m and midnight 35
dude people age 25-34 have the highest
amount of drivers involved in car
crashes all right we're both past that
still if you're 25 34 you're gonna get
an accident people age 15 to 24 have the
highest rate of emergency room it's due
to car accidents of all age groups all
right and young and listen submit an
injury claim with Morgan Morgan is so
freaking easy if you're ever injured
okay you can check out our friends at
Morgan Morgan it's freaking easy it's
more like using an app than hiring a
freaking lawyer submitting a claim to
Morgan Morgan's easy as well it's
probably as easy as pie I'd say I know
you're gonna say submitting your claim
to Morgan Morgan is it's as easy as
pretending you didn't see that 5 PM
email from your boss with Morgan
submitting a claim is as easy as hitting
snooze on your alarm for the eighth time
sure man the bottom line is it's
actually incredibly quick submit a claim
to Morgan Morgan's easier than okay
that's gonna keep going listen
reclaim with Morgan Morgan is so
freaking easy how easy is it dude it's
too easy it's like ordering a ride sure
after after a night all right man I'm
done on the examples Morgan Morgan is
America's largest injury Law Firm
they've offered over 100 offices
Nationwide and more than 800 freaking
lawyers with over 15 billion dollars
recovered for its clients
[Music]
Morgan Morgan has proven track record of
fighting to get you your full and fair
your average injured you can check out
Morgan Morgan their fee is free unless
they win for more information go to
forthepeople.com fighter or dial pound
law pound 529 from your cell phone
that's
fourforthepeople.com fighter or pound
law pound 529 from your cell
this is a bad advertisement Morgan
Morgan uh man dude you know what we
messed up because you and I eat so many
freaking macadamia nuts yeah Bill
Bellamy is here and we're not gonna send
him on his way with some nuts we should
have said I'm on our way we should have
set him on his way with some some uh
chocolate covered nuts chocolate covered
nuts magic Minds some other stuff too
you know what you could do to show them
you're nuts I could do that too hey Bill
would you rather see these old man's
nuts would you have some tasty macadamia
nuts in your mouth Damien that's not as
big as my nuts because I got big nuts
yeah you do but there but they're not
talking they're a lot more buttery and
yours aren't as tasty I could cover my
nuts and chocolate but I guarantee they
don't taste as good as the chocolate it
was on the expensive either let's be
honest now now I'm so addicted my and
I'm in my 15 month old baby got a hold
of some of them chocolate he's already a
nut lovers and it's a big problem he's a
nut lover it's a big problem because he
he eats them all dude you would think
that it's they're good for you it is the
most expensive and rare of nuts but
listen please scroll down
they got they got come on they got
naturally occurring
omega-7 fatty acids which they say are
some of the healthiest I guess fats you
could be how do they make the nuts so
freaking cheap and macadamia nuts
okay they own it's look Farmers they
they they partner with South African
rural uh communities and they have over
90 Farmers dude get to it hand sorted
nuts natural flavors dipped sugar-free
chocolate macadamia bars how about the
bars daddy macadamia nuts creamy nut
Butters put on your face extra cold
pressed extra virgin macadamia nut oil
which is what I use all the time now
dude if people are jonesing their mouth
is salvating right now for limit time
we're giving you guys a free box of the
45 Macadamia snack bars 45 you get one
of each flavors then you can pick then
order and save 20 off your entire order
when you use the code tfak all you gotta
do is go to House of
macadamias.comtfak you get the Macadamia
snack bars plus 20 entire order with the
code tfak House of macadamias enjoy damn
dog Bill Bellamy why haven't I seen you
anymore I miss you bro you never see the
same right number's still the same okay
I've been on the road podcasting and
Road hey man I just did mine yesterday I
knocked out three did you I mean damn do
you know now we're on the strike I got a
movie coming out camping promoted no way
yeah you can't do it you did you just
did a special you said no I did I have a
movie coming out called uh back to the
strip with
Wesley Snipes Kevin Hart JB's move damn
that's a good one about it you can't
even talk about it that's what they said
yeah they just send out a mandate
we can still podcast I mean you're just
you're just saying what you're saying
right now is you can't promote it
does the movie still come out yeah
yeah but we can't we can't say you know
I'll go to the theaters we can't like
it's [__] up like when can you think
you could like hold the release to some
of this well it already is already was
in motion we we come out in theaters on
the 18th yeah for me on the 15th
I just was on the chat with the fellas
I'm like dog I think we hit bro
I think we hit and we got a good trailer
out we got Buzz I can't wait I want to
see it you play strippers like we play
like hilarious oh hysterical bro it's
like we're like these strippers that
used to be the chocolate chips and you
know
already yeah
and we can't so you see you had to you
had to get in shape and do all that and
then Kevin is one of them too Kevin no
Kevin is he's he's not one of the
chocolate chips Wesley is hilarious yeah
Kevin Kevin Scott though he looks good
stuff he looks good he looks he's still
blade you see him blade up still blade
it up yeah but but uh
hilarious back on the Strip oh that
there's now can can you can you promote
it on your own individual like social
media like Instagram and stuff I was I
was doing I was doing it before uh the
Mandate just came out yesterday
they were saying like you know we're not
late man it's crazy it's like we're not
promote appearances
if they said something about podcasting
but you can't you can't promote on
podcasts so I can't talk about my move
we just got to kick it that's almost
that's so strange and then also because
they want to they want to squeeze them
out
do you know what I mean because
basically you know they're these
[__] don't want to break past
nothing bro like this is not even close
like yeah it's like light years away you
know and unfortunately unfortunately
because of technology I don't think we
win this I don't know how we win it
because what we're saying is pay right
or so so watch this you're a writer you
you get a show on Netflix Netflix buys
seven of those episodes for the season
if you're lucky 10 but it's really seven
or six or eight right you know you can't
first of all you can't make your living
that way how much you're getting paid as
a writer 14 Grand huh because if you
don't want the next guy I'll take it and
that's a lot of them it's not even about
it after taxes and everything else
you're maybe seeing Seven Grand you
don't know about that it's not about
that the the issues residuals no no it's
not even about that this year they're
having is with chat gbt and Technology
yeah they they're like man instead of
paying seven Riders this chat GPT can
knock this stuff out like and where's it
gonna be in two years three years that I
kind of worry less about right I
shouldn't
I I think what they're really more
worried about though is that there's not
enough they're not there's not enough
money so when is the life that shows
that it's the likeness then the likeness
thing What's creepy is that they could
do a
of you and use it for forever to do Ai
and then not pay him right now that's
crazy you see but but see it's just like
you guys I don't know how old you are
but when Napster first came out it's the
same feeling it's a wait a minute what's
gonna happen to the music industry right
music industry has never been the same
no we stopped going to record stores we
stopped buying music we now we share we
[__] just you know we pay a fee to
listen yeah back in the day we had to
buy so now if you let's say 10 years
from now what you think it's going to be
bro it's gonna be crazy it's and that's
the fight you guys are going yeah that's
what we're trying to figure out because
it's like
with AI with the with the streamers
having a built-in reservoir of money
built in they got subscribers right so
they're loaded so they're they're trying
to outbeat the networks they'll pay you
2 million dollars to do this movie okay
cool but that's it
no more residual no nothing but like we
live on residuals of health plans all
this [__] and we help them
so if if everybody does a buyout the
union dies you know I I got to tell you
because I always felt precarious from
day one anyway I just about what about
our Union about how actually we're not
talking about this well because I I know
I was well I was thinking about this I
was like where's this energy six years
ago well I was uh because because I was
thinking
I was thinking about this 20 years ago I
was like [__]
you at the party wouldn't think about
that
because you know what though
but when you do a sitcom you'd make you
could make 35 40 I think my last sitcom
I was making a lot like way more than
that twice that and and uh but I knew I
I would have done it for a fraction that
cost especially when I was starting out
and I was like
all of us as actors just want work
somehow it got you we got gamed in and
now we're making yeah but remember back
in the day when you got a sitcom back in
the day right like 20 people don't
realize but 25 years ago 20 years ago
when you got a CBS NBC you you were
buying a house well that's what comments
you wanted right like a lot of people
started staying up just to get that
correct because then you could see Brian
and you were making TV money and we call
that that you you were gonna buy a house
you were set yeah you got residuals it
was beautiful and sometimes if you did
one show because the way things were
structured and it went five years oh my
God right and it went 10 years oh my God
it's a wrap you can lead the game
correct and if you and if you said if
you created the show like now you're now
you got 50 100 million dollars in the
bank 200 million dollars those days are
gone those days are gone those days are
gone well even homeboy that created that
massive show what's the Asian show we
love Chad squid game oh he they were
like he was he was going around he was
like you know my family thinks you know
I'm like balling making all this money
and he released how much he made like
sold the rice sweet game it was the
biggest show ever on Netflix I think he
sent me like a hundred grand for the
rights he goes now the second season is
going to be different I'm gonna get paid
but everyone's asked me for money I made
about 100 Grand off that entire season
oh my God yeah all right there you go
because Netflix's like nah you need us
and then it's this huge hit now he has
leverage but what's your chance of
having a huge hit like that these days
you never know I mean like the guy who
uh did Desperate Housewives right he was
home that's right he was homeless living
in his car blah blah blah and he wrote
that series and changed his life like
you don't hear about him because he
don't give a [__] he done or he could do
whatever you want to do I mean it can
happen you know what I mean if you you
could still make a lot of money in
network TV but like the amount of shows
they're making now are smaller so the
window of opportunity is like nah but
isn't there more places you can go like
more streams yeah
you can yeah but you get over the
streamers and then they'll you know they
do buyouts or they do some tricky [__]
you know whatever don't you happy you
have stand up yeah I'm surprised you
never did a podcast
you do yeah nobody can tell a story like
you do yeah I got time feeling top
billing I've been doing since last July
I'm like I'm up to like 55 apps is it
you inspired you have one with spares
too right don't you yeah yeah I do yeah
I did he was on he was on a couple weeks
ago oh he's just a guy yeah he was just
a guest yeah he's he was he was really
he was a grandkid
I have I've had everybody had magic uh I
had Dewayne Wade Stephen A Smith uh I
was Stephen A Smith he was hilarious he
he was buried Stephen A he's such a
talent right but you realize like like
like like he's a real journalist like he
can't get some [__] he's a writer he was
a writer in Philadelphia yeah grinding
it out [__] grinding it out got a
little bit of this got a mentor boom bad
boom now he's like executive producer he
got crazy ass TV deal with uh with
Disney are you from New York originally
Jersey that's right yeah that's right so
mid Jersey but yeah but I'm glad you're
doing that because nobody can tell a
story like he tell we'd be we did this
movie together bro you know me I take a
room over I swear you know I I'm always
the guy doing this stuff this dude shows
up I have bright and this dude shows up
nobody can tell a story like him he just
goes there and the next thing you know
I'm just quiet and so is everybody else
all the girls I'm looking at him
everybody else is it was just it was
beautiful
my the bummers I never got to see you
after that but we spent yeah I received
in the airport a couple times yeah you
know I bumped I bumped into you several
times after that right yep you know okay
but we're always like I know you know
like my kids you know my daughter's in
college I'm gonna be a junior my son how
old are you uh me I'm 56. me too
[__] you man yeah I know bro he looks
better I already gave him a compliment
it happened
don't you do that either okay
just turned 17 last week star athlete
trying to get him a scholarship you know
what's going out the [__] house uh
basketball he's pretty good six six
plays what he plays the three oh dope
your old family's tall right oh yeah oh
is Alex looking for me I'm here Alex
Alex what up
I'm in here we're talking we're
podcasting man we interrupting our
conversation
now um so you got so he's that good an
athlete six six yeah six six uh where's
he play he plays at Campbell Hall so now
so so my nephews went there yeah my
nephew played soccer there LeBron's kids
are there so Bryce just came over so now
we're the new Sierra Canyon so now my
sons can play he's gonna be on [__]
get some exposure yeah he's gonna get
like he's just about to get the exposure
he really get is he starting yeah on
that team yeah well he can't be talking
about going College if he's not starting
well so so Sierra Canyon where my where
my other nephews in nisco they have the
best I think they have the best high
school basketball team where they they
did what they did six or seven years
they did when uh brownie was there and
then Scottie Pippen Amari uh Amari
Stoudemire no no Amari what Mari Bailey
Bailey's theirs he just went pro but he
went there he went to UCLA UCLA for one
year as far as Sports because they're
like number one baseball yeah they they
push our athletes but but LeBron's and
Chris Paul's kids are now at Campbell
they left yeah they want to do their own
so so basically lebroni's last year was
last year he's going to be a freshman at
USC so LeBron took his youngest son
Bryce brought him to Campbell Hall wrote
a fat check to build us a new gym so you
know his son gonna play yeah right but
the thing is my son's a senior and my
son's six six and you know he's pretty
good so I'm like it's just I told Baron
this is just a win-win for you it's a
win-win because those Scouts are going
to come for LeBron's son and then see
this dude Hold Up Wait A Minute who the
[__] is that yeah and he's definitely
impact too it's like it's not enough
does he feel pressure it's just
different now like I don't know
like the eyeballs and Instagram and and
I helped him a little bit has to right
yeah because it's like it's like being
put on
um
the spotlight hot but he's got dad who's
been in the spotlight forever yeah but
I'm just saying like he's getting ready
we're not 16. but when I told him I
literally I told him the other day I
said don't get in your head do what you
do do what you do don't [__] these
people ignore the noise yo block that
[__] out do you you you train for this
this is what you do so don't get caught
up in your head and you're screaming and
all like just play ball he was like and
then I seen him get you know settled in
because it's just like everybody's you
know people and people are talking [__]
they're celebrities then he got online
where people talking [__] they're
basically not celebrities they are well
imagine this yeah LeBron's son when his
last year at Sierra Cannon he was the
highest paid nil kid he's making two
million dollars what are you talking
about he was 70 yeah you could sign in a
name image and likeness so now you can
be paid as an amateur athlete I'm
thinking two million a year in 19 making
2 million your friend's like damn how
good is his son how tall is his son six
four six four he's a guard I respect him
though I respect him because he because
of who his dad is he grew up in that
Spotlight yes and they were kind of
hating on him but then in the McDonald's
game he balled out he balled out like he
has a lot of pressure on him you know
now if he's not LeBron's son is he is he
going to be a draft pick I don't know
because they're talking about LeBron is
going to play until he won't retire
until he can play with his son wow so
whoever drafts him they're gonna expect
to get LeBron too it's it's it I don't
know I mean I like I like that you know
LeBron is is strong arming his kids like
I [__] do it you know what I'm saying
I I barter my relationships to get my
son's opportunity right but it's like
but you still gotta be good though
you got to understand bro
you can get in there but you can't stay
in here now the [__] is good
bro like you got Scottie Pippen's son in
in the league he's so far on the bench
he in the tunnel yeah yeah is that true
is that true yeah he's way out yo he's
way down there the way son in Africa
playing
I'm not [__]
Martin's son yes I saw it came right the
other day
because I can't I know sports right so
Kenyan KJ what is six nine ball and now
he's not as good as his dad no but he's
super athletic six nine and he's a
springy he jumps out the gym and he just
got traded to a good team like uh
somebody real is he OKC now so yeah I
think so he he's assault he's gonna be
all right he's a solid player he's in
college he earned it no he's in the NCAA
and he earned it last time I when I seen
KJ break before he went to to uh I think
he went to college for one year right
yeah his dad's like my son's going pro I
was like what I saw him I saw him at
Syria again I was saying oh my God yep
you know it yeah you know you just
you've done it long enough and he's like
yep because because you'll see upside
you can see upside you can see size you
can see skill like you see certain
things everybody's not LeBron bro that's
one percent of the world Zion Williams
that's a one percent situation a
[__] Derek Jeter that's a one
percent yeah everybody else get better
or you know keep chipping at it yeah but
like my son to me is like a guy I give
you a pervers I'm like my son would be
like a guy like Andrew Wiggins right
he's Slinky he's athletic he's Scrappy
he contributes on all he plays the game
the right way he wants that guy also you
can't everybody can't be part of more of
a quarterback kind of a well I think he
plays like utility player like he'll fit
in yeah he'll get done at the highest
level that's why the NBA that's why the
Nuggets won the championship absolutely
and utility players that when it counted
they got the John Tuck like Aaron Gordon
yeah you see how good curse you know
Eric Gordon
Aaron Gordon Aaron Gordon on the Denver
Nuggets if he was on another team B
Superstar
but on that team for Jamal jokic he's
utility-ish but he kills he's Kitty
though oh he's okay
you can't leave him and they leave him
they leave him he bust your ass and he's
also because he wasn't really [__] at
Orlando he won the dunk contest he
wasn't really shitties whatever and
comes in now he's just the right
situation his Ballers around him but
people people forget he was literally
the best high school basketball player
in the country bro he was number one as
a kid he was a freak like you my school
freak then get strapped by Orlando and
he was like it didn't really work out he
won the dunk contest comes the Nuggets
because he has those other like key
players baller might be the best defense
player I mean 6-10 first of all Damon or
seven foot shuts shuts you down like
he's the one who shut down speed and
everything Butler I got everything bro
that's what I'm saying like it's
sometimes a situation sometimes it's
just Raw Talent like you know what I
mean people people don't understand how
hard it is to be elite you got all these
kids only about them a hundred of them
gonna get past one level like all like
literally there's only four kids that
could play the next level on my team
right now on my son's team and that's
why it's college basketball yeah yeah
only four four
that's it did you play any ball yeah I
played I played in high school I didn't
play in college but think about a big
thing and then I can see it too and
everybody know it yeah oh you you're
different your son's done your son's
done he said that's it his son's going
it's like if you see it it's like it's
Alpha in the room you can run drills and
all that sorry bro I don't give a [__]
you playing for fun bro
some of the kids quit because they just
know it ain't good enough for that
because it's you got to make a trip I
think that's the problem because now
like my son's in this Elite baseball and
all the parents talking about he's gonna
play for the Dodgers and Padres I'm like
you [__] out of your mind man how
about they just have fun yeah who knows
where they go they forget they put so
much pressure I'm like no no just let
them have fun man you'll know
even at that age of seven like my son
he's a baller he's getting good but then
Matt kem's son is there oh I I tell him
I just put blockers on my stomach don't
look over here that's not for you I just
going places you're not going right but
here's the thing here's the thing
because I'm glad we're talking like this
what parents what if I've learned
you'd rather your son be a late bloomer
hell is so many kids are jumping around
they jump out and then they just level
out so so tennis is a sport that if you
don't know it's a world-class I mean
it's a World Cup if you don't start when
you are
yeah there was a girl who was the
national champion she was 11 years old I
was watching it I was watching the head
she was Junior Nationals and I was like
I was watching her and she looked so
different than everybody else she was
just coming off the ground and and her
coach uh who I knew was like I know but
it's just a it's a tragic of what he
goes she didn't Groove her stroke right
she's she's hitting wrong but she's so
athletic but she's getting away with it
and yeah and and said we're trying to
change her stroke but he goes I think
it's too late I go she's 11. he goes I
know but she's about to be 12. yeah he
goes I don't think it's possible but it
might be and I'm like so you what are we
talking about so they gotta lock you in
at six and a half yes now here's the
other thing
they're very careful though because kids
who are at the national level when
they're young a lot of times burnout
don't make it to the pros so the way
they like the Spaniards the serbians the
Russians bring you up is very slowly
there's a whole song yeah well you can
burn out anyway did a lot of other
sports so a lot of those guys did a lot
they played soccer they did a lot of
[__] until they were about 15 16 then
came home now we go now we go
well yeah you don't want to burn it out
it's like you even when we were in high
school like the one kid who had it all
he had the muscles at the bus station
15. yeah ain't doing [__] [__]
you're dominating High School what's up
now baby like hey man what's up Josh you
had armpit here
boy 160. yeah and doing [__]
but what's good he had all the [__]
okay
go up in 11th grade I knew my time was
coming though what I just sat back in
the shadow I was a late bloomer so I was
super late I was a super late Boomer I
didn't I didn't I didn't come out the
box being like Oh Bill Bellamy it man
it's I love the lake because I remember
that's why you're a comic man listen bro
it's something for that like the swan
like you know you get to mature you get
to you know get to know yourself a
little better and you know more content
still feel a little skinny and small
yeah
I think you need that as a comic like
right ugly butterfly yeah
they call it the shadow you got to feel
a little bit like you need that you got
to feel a little bit I I don't think it
was a guy who came up to me young guy
and cameras bro beautiful looking guy
muscular big and he goes I want to be a
comic would you have any advice I go
lose weight you got to stop working out
so much I go I need you to not like
yourself as much do you like yourself
just you gotta he liked himself just a
little bit too much too straight
everything's like this I need to be you
got to feel like your clothes absolutely
like Matt Rife
I was saying you he's the most gorgeous
comedian that's at his level it doesn't
make sense and then I find out he he was
the ugly duckling like when he was 16 he
had big-ass buck teeth yeah baseball
field he got it together yeah and then
he got his [__] together I've known
matches you couldn't grow up like you
can't literally known Matt since she was
19. he was like yeah but he but he loves
himself he looks good I know he but he
laying he leans into that Tick Tock that
Tick Tock took him out he also works
hard so Matt Matt has it Matt was always
up there doing stuff he was always
performing funny it's funny it's Talent
what are we going to talk about man you
can make we wasting all this good
content all this good content this is
what we talking about this real [__]
real [__] what's his show [__] that's
true that's very true what do you got
what do you got for me what's going on
what's on your mind what do you think of
the state of the world I think what's
crazy like when you blew up was it Def
Comedy Jam yeah 91 going into 92. and
how long was that set on Def Comedy Jam
six minutes six minutes ducky fresh yeah
um so I made it with six minutes I
really only needed foreign I like that I
like the story about you how Oliver
Stone looked to you I think it was you
and he goes
so so
Any Given Sunday
one of my favorite movies I'm
represented by CAA
um
Oliver Stone's there you know CAA to me
was like the king of packaging projects
you know put pieces together directors
and actors right so we had
Jamie Foxx you had LL Cool J Matthew
Modine uh Cameron Diaz James Woods like
Al Pacino like this is Rocky [__] no and
so uh uh
my agent said Oliver Stone would like to
meet you I said what
are you kidding me out of a stone oh my
God right so I go to Santa Monica to his
office I meet him and he's like just
like kind of like genius kind of like
quirky cat he looking at my picture
looking at me looking at my picture it's
like a Bellamy huh yeah he got a lot of
us got a lot of us I can't play football
I'm like I'm pretty athletic
can you play football this guy Jimmy
Sanderson like he gives me like the bio
of the character he's got like 12 pages
of who this guy is and he's got Dion
there and different players that kind of
embody this character right I said dog I
think I could do all that bro I got all
of that in me I said um
it's up to you you say well we'll see
I'll see you at USC tomorrow
that just like that just like that okay
so so even if you had the conference in
the room he wanted to see that [__] on
the fish damn so we was at USC like the
next morning I said oh [__]
oh [__] every actor in Hollywood was at
that and you got to run routes now
because now I'm running routes
yeah yeah yeah
but but the part that was crazy I never
got a football thrown to me by a real
quarterback though yeah so they had some
college guys out there throwing in some
Pro guys through it so you got to run 60
yards you got to run 40 yards you got to
run Slants you got to run hooks so okay
now if you lied you're gonna get your
tapped and the funny is [__] are we live
because this is funny yeah we've been
like we've been logged the whole time oh
great no the funniest you think we've
been rolling this whole time oh that's
perfect so here's the funniest [__]
right
you didn't want to get this thank you
this is this dude they want this right
here because they was going around
tapping [__]
he's like go ahead man don't attack the
Terrible
cause it was like
like bundling after lunch so like okay
we had the running backs we had the
quarterbacks and we had the receivers
and there was actors out there trying to
get it
take my role like major act like big
time actors out there
I want to say all right yeah
but I'm telling you they was huffing and
puffing trying to get it and I was
smoking every last one of them every
last one I'm catching [__] with one hand
catch your hand over here over the top I
was I was the best day ever right the
one the one that I caught that killed me
you know when you catch the football
you're supposed to be diamonds right
yeah a lot of times you do this the
basket the basket is is not that good
because if you don't catch it it's gonna
hit you boom and I smothered it but it
blew my [__] up right here like bro
I think I [__] on myself right so so he
was like
right I didn't want to drop the balls
and it took about 30 hours for your air
to come back but it feels like it right
it was like 13 Seconds of
it was like thank you good job Bellamy
good good job I go to my car I lift up
my shirt I am burgundy blue and black
God that's how hard they can throw it I
never knew somebody could break you
could hear you could hear the football
coming like a baseball
I'll say oh [__] now you could hear a
baseball too on the field yeah
I bet some actors got [__] up out
they're like oh this is because they
were because this is a movie you guys
were hitting each other
in the movie we were getting hit but in
in the workouts you just they wanted you
like L L Cool J had to run like Run come
you know pitch outs and just there was a
lot of acne he's athletic yeah he's
after 235 pounds but he didn't have to
run the routes he had to look like a
runner it's easier than that's easier
than running routes yes
running routes it's like
kind of like almost like drawing like
you know remember he had to draw the
bunny like you could lie and say you're
an artist and say Here's the bunny right
oh yeah how do I draw the ears how do I
you know but when you run routes you
know you got to run a slant you got to
run a Post Corner you know
you know come back boom and you gotta
get your head around like so there's
certain things that they'll be looking
for they're like okay and I wasn't all
the way there yet but they saw that I
had the potential so right they're a
teacher so now I mean you know I'm at
the camp and you know I'm working out
twice a day and you know I'm running
routes every day best shape of my life
I've never ran every day every day crazy
for hours like just sprinting just
stride outs but also they wanted you
guys to look the part too because it's
like Lawrence Taylor was there we have
real football tips I know can I tell you
my Michael Clark Duncan Story please
okay rest in peace Michael another big
man Michael Clark Duncan was probably
the biggest human being I ever seen as
an actor like just like like specimen of
a man like voice Kofi like to drink you
know big [__] right and he had
no Sports background right at all
he told me you came from Chicago I think
he worked underground it is you know the
deuce like DWP or some [__] imagine that
coming out of manhole right just a giant
man just a big guy great guy by the way
so we get to we get to camp and he's
supposed to be technically LT the big
powerful linebacker that is going to
destroy you you come around the edge
he's going to knock the letters off your
shirt that's basically what it is right
so Mike ain't really a football player
and you can tell but he's big than the
[__] with the shoulder pads on
all the players like God damn we're
gonna tackle that [__] right
so Oliver Stone it was a it was a half
back sweep and it was coming to him and
he had to blow the running back up right
so he comes around
and he just hugs the dude Oliver jumps
out the tent what and you know you take
the headphones off like a real head
coach and the [__] was that Michael he
was like Oliver what do you mean I ain't
want to hurt nobody
he said that's the character are you
kidding me I didn't fly you down here to
be his [__] friend I flew you out
here to kill him
do it again damn Oliver don't talk to me
like that man you don't know me like
that man but he mad that okay you want
me to show you right so he puts his dick
up he's like all right right left right
he come around again
Michael Clark Duncan is going like 90
miles an hour he hits the dude so far
somebody that's dead somebody passed
away
somebody that hit this man so hard he
went off the field and knocked down
three people oh no
and then Michael hit him and laid on the
girl oh
everybody's like what the [__] it went
from great Hit Radio
God
Echo get up I can't mate okay mate
I put I told him a pic I told my [__]
pig
they're not built for that no really
actors against Joey tripped his pick off
the [__] bone damn bro I didn't even
know you could rip a pet listening to
our injuries in football like you don't
realize what the guy's going he knows
about you liver that's about it though
I'm getting hit hard playing football
for so long but I I didn't have any
major injuries but guys get [__] up a
lacerated liver lacerated it means it
got hit and it got mangled a little yeah
like cut yeah my update I got hit in the
ribs and my ribs broke and ran into my
liver ah so what do they do that's
nothing
yeah I was just out for the rest of my
senior season oh yeah that's not a good
injury no that's not a good one you know
what's worse
I saw that quarterback who quit and then
you saw the list of injuries and it was
like it was astonishing you're like what
the [__] what are we talking about here
football over a longevity of times bad
yeah I mean UFC but you UFC's on what I
learned from you're never well you play
what positions you play tight end you
play tight end so you can relate to this
all the football all the football
players that I played with in that movie
told me has to be to kill you gotta go
full speed on everything oh yeah you
can't play around like uh that's how you
get hurt full speed everything is real
time like practice how you play wow
that's basically what I learned from
football players like all that have
speed you know I'm just chilling you get
[__] you got to keep your aggression
you got shot Any Given Sunday where in
Miami and uh in Dallas did you coin the
term booty call yes sir I told you yeah
man you got all that you thought you got
all that booty for yourself
all them calls you made that was your
boy right there bro you're on ten
percent
give me them that's an impressive
culture defining I mean that's that's
what you call it historic oh my god dude
this this dude was interviewing me he
was like yo man you you invented a booty
call that's like [__] it ain't going
nowhere no
it's true
like a glow job is gonna stick forever
yeah whoever came up with [__] that
was a good one oh yeah yeah
put it goes better actually though yeah
booty that's graphic yeah
it's intense but booty calls like yo man
get another one of those today yes
men and women use it interchangeably too
the government should give you your day
match yeah
booty call Tuesdays yeah man like taco
Tuesday booty cartoon I can't believe
you can't promote your movie but can we
take a little break I need some good
supplements dude and I want to stay hard
I want to get hard I want to stay hard
here's the thing dude I take care of
myself but I need a little something I
can be honest with you can I tell you
yeah there's nothing we can do for you
there's nothing nothing at your age what
about that company called on it on it on
they try our best listen if you need the
best in trouble on the planet we're
talking about Alpha Brain daddy we got
Alpha Brain instant Black Label Focus
shot pre-workout what if I want to sleep
dude sure man got melatonin spray yeah
we got
some total gut health we swear just for
my joints and stuff yeah we got all that
we got creaked in with some muscle on
your body we got Warrior bars protein
bars protein powders vitamins yeah
whatever dude streaming Fitness steel
Club Macy's we got it all go to
audit.com
f-a-t-k try ten percent Knockouts yeah
do it save 10 off everything we just
listed especially the best nootropic on
the planet we're talking about Alpha
Brain on it.com f-a-d-k let's get back
to Bill Bellamy I I wanna where at least
tell me where it's coming out well I'll
just tell I'll tell you uh what the
movie is it's called back to the strip
it's a very very funny uh comedy about
these guys you know who were at one
point in their careers like really the
top strippers like they wear the best
chocolate chip outside you know they
like the brothers from Down Under and
all that Thunder from Down on there they
were the chocolate chips you know and so
they now they're a little older the
chips the chips ain't it so chocolatey
yeah
Chris Spencer directed it first time
director yes and then uh so we had so we
had Wesley Snipes Kevin Hart
um spin some more
um Tiffany haddish Faison love JB Smoove
and Gary Oldman we got a nice we got a
nice little casty lineup yeah we
beasting it and uh you know well
hopefully you know eventually it'll come
out and people get a chance to enjoy it
you know hopefully you know the strike
we can come up with something that is
you know Equitable for the actors and
writers and people that do what we do
you know everybody can't be as funny as
me and you you know bro they can't my
friend and also Dr Stanley thank God
also the problem is is selfishly I might
have [__] to watch they don't figure
this out well they got stuff in the can
they always know like this ain't our
first strike so this is the funny thing
about strikes in Hollywood right when
they even know the contracts are up or
gonna come up and they don't want to get
stuck they start just stop cranking it
out they get a bunch of scripts they get
everything you know so that they got a
little bit of surplus
if they didn't do that they'd be stuck
still your sense is that this is going
to last for a while
my sense is that it will not last for a
long time because I think that at
ultimately
right will win and I think that the
greed part of it they they just have to
understand that
the entertainment business Hollywood
that's a part of our culture like that's
the thing that you know has existed for
quite some time and it's important to
what America is you know the way we
produce films and actors and actresses
and the different things that we are
putting into the culture I think it's
important for us to take care of the
culture right you know I want the next
wave of great actors to come in you know
I want more comics to come in I want
more writers to come in you don't want
people to just get turned off from our
business and not want to be a part like
that's where I moved to L.A right you
know what I mean back in the day I was
like man Hollywood like to me Hollywood
just look like anything could happen you
could make it and it could and if you're
like a change right like like like I
always felt like going to Hollywood was
like going to Vegas yo I could hit dude
how many times I remember they were
doing this campaign they'd seen
everybody for this Bud Light campaign
with this guy I don't remember Wendell
he was a Bud Light guy uh not Bud Light
I'm sorry Miller Light Miller High Life
okay remember that black guy Wendell he
said Greg he died passed away one yeah
yeah yeah I remember when so so they
were doing this whole new thing and
they'd seen and when I say everybody I
mean everybody it didn't matter if it
was Australia England they couldn't find
the guy this is they go crazy with this
stuff
I'm on I'm literally in Gene's T-shirt
with these black dresses I was gonna go
hike or something like that yeah I gotta
you got an audition
I'm like what you know you're gonna I
walk in on my way to do a I want to go
to Topanga Canyon hike I don't want to
do this [__] I'm really not really
want to be here today
got us a man like this and he goes uh I
walk in and I got a little scruff and he
goes so you're just a guy moving a box
and then he's gonna come in and then
you're gonna see him and I want you to
react like it's just weird I'm like
so I literally I go I pick it up I put
it down I go
that's it
that's why
said to their address not bad it was
good
that's why I was like you got the gig
but yeah
look at me I'm a good actor
it's subtle quality
I made probably more than 500k because
it was a campaign and they kept running
it I said to the director I go what was
it about me because I don't know you
just had a look blue collar look
and that's what it comes down to
sometimes in an afternoon and that paid
my year but those those days are over
you're saying and I did the same thing
with Gillette I remember with Gillette I
don't know what I don't even remember
what happened they wanted a Gillette guy
that turned into a 400 some odd thousand
dollar uh campaign because I you know
why she had that average face I have
that average face but you got that
you're like you like you are the
quintessential guy like American guy
that's what they said you know I was
just Scrappy it's like you know you look
like you know how to fix a 454 Chevy
yeah you look like you look like you got
like not a meat pie like a nice little
[__] lawnmower or somewhere
yeah
and you look like you put a paneling
like you can put it up like like you
look like you know how to use a nail gun
don't he yeah you know I don't know how
to do any of that exactly I gotta hire
people for anything yeah it's got no
[__] no I'm talking about I don't know
how to do anything
my wife my wife my wife before we were
dating and I bought uh uh I bought a
veteran a is a long story so it gets
stolen and it comes back the cops find
it in 20 hours or whatever and and it's
it's bunched up but the bottom part is
hanging that like the so I'm like you
know bottom I noticed I don't know
anything about cars I got the bottom
part the bottom part is
the catalytic converter now the bottom
flap if there's a flap that's hanging so
I go I'm like I got to take this to the
I got to take this now
I have the experts just slap the bottle
flap my wife didn't grow up with money
she my wife just goes she she looks down
she's my girlfriend she just looks nice
she goes what what do you have to do I
go see the flap is hanging down she goes
she gets on her hands and he just looks
at it she reached over grabs a piece of
strings just under on her back like that
just ties up she goes it was it was the
stuff
I was like you're a genius that's
amazing he's not gonna marry you and I
married her and you married her baby you
know how to fix a flap your kids never
want to get an entertainment did you
push them away from it no I don't know I
don't know I mean my daughter did
I mean she did a couple things um in
high school she actually in grammar
school in middle school she was doing
like plays and stuff like that and then
you know then she kind of kind of got
shy a little bit came back to it again
uh she did some stuff in her sophomore
year college and I was like wow do you
are you going to be an actress she was
taking a lot of classes and she stopped
so I think it's in there I think it's
kind of in there a little bit and my
daughter's really funny which is which
is really crazy because I'm like I would
expect my son to be funny and he is but
he's a different style of funny like you
know he is like trying to be cool you
know the you know the teenage kind of
like Dad what's up I'm taller than you
you know but he has a he's very very
much a uh fun guy around his friends
sometimes I just sit in the car and I
just watch how easy like he's the center
of attention so he's a pretty good kid
man it's like I don't know if I want
somewhere to be a
an actor off the top I want them to get
to education I think I think it's
important to have a a balance like I
feel like that's what happened to me you
know I didn't know I was going to be an
actor and make movies and stuff I was
just I lived like a civilian like I just
live the regular Jersey life and you
know uh stand up I just started doing
stand up in college bro like on some
[__] like you know they had a coffee
house can you can can you host
oh [__] they need a hose I've been up
there and do it and I just jumped up
there that we we got 75 in college
that's like seven thousand years
so I'm like I do it I like it I'm like
dang this [__] is kind of fun just up
here talking and I'm improving a little
bit what's your name where you from oh
and I was just doing jokes off of that
kind of stuff not really a joke joke
tell yet
fell in love with it and then um
I brought my junior year I'm like dog if
I could do anything outside of work at
you know IBM I would love to be a
stand-up I I saw certain people doing it
I still had a job I would never get this
one of my one of my guys comedian out of
New York his name was Reggie McFadden
and Reggie used to always get on me
about having a job
he was a full-time comp he was like yeah
you still got that you still got that
job huh I was like yeah he was saying 40
000 a year buddy company car not so bad
out of college yeah he said you ain't no
real [__] comedian until this
is all you do oh
okay get out of your skin right hurt me
so hard he was like you don't really
want it if the same everything you do
Bill and tell you and tell you that's
this is all you're doing you shouldn't
even come to the comedy club I'll never
forget when he says that probably right
and I was like one day I'm gonna quit
this [__] and so I I did I quit
I ended up quitting the job but like I
remember you know
that was a blessing that he told me that
because he was like yo you got to commit
all the way you can't half-ass it if I
saw talented yeah they tell you to quit
yeah what I like about you is you love
people yeah and and you you never act
like you're better than anybody like
we'd be doing a movie and and we'd be in
we were in Charlotte North Carolina and
people would come out to build you know
oh my God you know and he you would get
up and you'd go over and you would just
start talking to them it wasn't anything
for you it was like you never were too
cool for school no I don't know I
learned from that actually I was always
that way but I really learned like well
you just you were just never you never
acted removed from it
no he makes them feel safe like he makes
them these two girls come over and it's
kind of like overweight and they're
whatever they are and they're just
excited because they probably work
shitty jobs and they come they see him
and they're like hi Kelly hi Bill
oh yeah he was oh what's up
he just come up and he's just like
messing around with him it was so great
man I think I was like you're cool to
even ugly people man
you can tell it no I think
um a lot of that comes from um being a
comedian too because
when you are a comedian and people are
entertained and they love you from that
and even though you're in the movie the
part that they know is your personality
yeah so I think when they come over to
you it'd be sad to make them feel like
oh man I feel the same way
this guy sucks I thought he was a cool
guy so I don't want to disappoint me I
try to remind myself like even when I'm
tired like last this past weekend I was
working and I was really hungry and the
food was not that good at the club and I
was like I wanted to have something more
healthy and I was kind of agitated I
guess and then the fans were so excited
I just had to take a deep breath and be
like okay well you know they paid to see
me and I I just got to suck it up right
now it's not their fault yeah I didn't
want to eat [__] chicken wings that
looked like they had an ebola yeah you
know what I'm saying so you know and
it's hard like you know it's hard to
juggle Fame right because you never know
when it's going to be off or on or when
it just turns away it comes and goes
yeah it comes and goes or whatever like
a stock right and
one of the things that I've always loved
about my career is that people treat me
like I'm their cousin like yo that got
my man bill yeah dog yo I Met You in
2013. I'm just coming out of the service
like they like but like you remember
yourself
Katie Foxx told me this correct me wrong
uh black fans are very different than
white fans like in a lot of ways like
like Jamie Foxx said like white fans
come on hi Mr Fox can I take a picture
yes black face black fans I got
something to do with you so hey fox stay
right there I'm going back to my car and
get my phone don't move yeah don't move
it's in the parking deck there's a
difference there's a different
familiarity I also feel like black fans
too like they're more loyal like they're
like oh they're not just gonna give up
on you like they they're down man unless
you do so they defend you yeah you got
to do something great like I'll give you
a perfect example of the difference
between black and white when it comes to
Comedy right so I was in Tampa
and there was this girl
um her mom I knew from MTV and she was
like Bill
my daughters are up and coming comic I
said you kidding me I haven't seen this
lady she's a producer at MTV in 25 years
whatever I said no problem your
daughter's new it don't matter I put on
my show tomorrow come tomorrow right
daughter is cute white girl great smile
could probably be on the sitcom
she ain't funny for [__] bro I couldn't
tell George she's not funny for [__]
yeah I've none of her [__] ain't going
and it's an all-black oh no oh no oh
Lord
my mom said around a suicide bro right
baptism by fire this is what black
people was doing while she was talking
oh I don't know who that is
bro they just got on the phone huh
Bill put somebody on this show right so
when I come on stage I reenact
everything that they the place went but
now all right I didn't answer and all
the white people were like give her a
chance
give her a chance she's new she's Brave
her heart is good at least she's trying
she's she's taking a good beating but
it's all right
no it's not going to happen with a black
body yeah I know black people don't give
a [__] about your feelings they don't
care that your mom in the audience they
work for a living room
I learned that the hard way because when
I was in what happened it might be I was
at the Miami Improv dude Miami but no I
already know what you got it was Miami
Improv but I was there for Showtime
because I was working the the Logan Paul
Floyd Mayweather fight okay but Miss Pat
was headlining oh Miss Pat and uh it's
all black all black and I didn't realize
how dirty she was in any of that stuff
like she we have a mutual friend in Tom
Segura and Rogan right and I wanted to
get working as I'm there I was there for
like four days so I need to get my sets
in so I'm like who's headline the the
manager's like what's Miss Pat I'm like
oh she she seems cool so I hit up so
girl I'm like hey uh I'm gonna open for
Miss Pat she was like yeah come on down
white boy I'm like all right so I go and
so girl was like don't [__] around hit
him like go for it man it's a black guy
go okay bro and I was like to open with
your clothes
[Music]
three minutes I finally get some laughs
I walk out I'm sweating everywhere then
miss Packers thanks honey thing goes out
and goes how y'all gonna cheer for that
white devil that came out here on this
stale
dude she lit me oh five minutes she went
hard in the paint bro I did I was in New
York comedy club in New York a novice
green as [__] I hadn't done stand up and
for I've been doing staff for 10 minutes
right all black crowd on a Tuesday night
or whatever it was and I get up there
and I decided to bro it's embarrassing I
decided I'm gonna do what it's like to
be reborn a penguin a legless flightless
bird in the middle of the South Pole oh
yeah you're about to get booed bro
I'm out there yeah
I'm like this I just hear about this
woman goes she goes
this one woman goes uh oh
and I just I go I'm gonna power through
and I start flapping my wings and then I
had this other woman go wow that was it
and it just I I well it's a good thing I
didn't quit everything I was like I want
to die I I should actually if I could
die right now it would be like this I'm
gonna tell you funny story funny is
story I've ever seen of a person taking
a bath in in in and not getting no
laughs right
hopefully this doesn't offend anybody
but this is definitely
it was it's a nightmare for coming I'm
doing the 15th annual HBO young comedian
special I remember it was it was taped
at Tempe Improv okay the famous Tempe
Improv Janine Garofalo Beastie Andy
Kindler yep Ray Romano
Bill Bellamy and uh
uh is it uh
uh oh my guys was it Rob Schneider no it
was it was he's a New York Comic it's
funny as [__] Patrice O'Neill no white
guy Italian
um oh oh uh uh Nick of Apollo
monster Nick de Paulo goes out there and
kicks a mud hole in it boom King Kong
that [__] I I'm I'm ready I'm
about to go to Hollywood set boom right
Janine Garofalo goes on after him
nice what did Lady say uh-oh
can I God bless her she can't call her
cannot stop any day because she's got
that kind of like yeah it didn't work
okay
here comes Andy Kindler
foreign
y can be really funny not today not that
guy
Andy Kindler had the set of hell oh no
he was like 50 minutes each he was both
of them back to back in a row I couldn't
help but win
could they set me up or not to win for a
year like because after that go worse
though Bellamy
you like with a machine with a bazooka I
was Bazooka Rambo whatever
I I mean it was just kill a room to
begin with just by I mean like I'm
saying to go from that to this it was
just like so I look like a king but it
was just because somebody else didn't
win but I was like I didn't know you
could get booed on the special
[__] that's that was my like that was
like my my wake-up call like you could
get boys
I thought specials are always like um
comedy is you could be Jesus Christ
himself if you don't if you bring funny
it doesn't matter who you are yeah after
three minutes of them going it's the
Messiah Here Comes it's getting quiet if
you're lucky it's getting quiet but
you're gonna have people going it's not
funny you're gonna have people go wow
wow okay or or go to their phone it's
just the way it is comedy uh earthquake
earthquake gave me one of the best sort
of like metaphors for uh for comedy he
said uh it's it's it's an occupational
hazard to be a comedian any night you go
to work you could die on the job I said
Why That's deep right but it makes sense
but he's been doing it it's a small
fraternity too it's a strange skill and
I think it requires a certain type of
Misfit and and uh it's it's a it's a
weird beautiful job to have Bill Bill at
your level did you get remember when
Chappelle was performing that dude
rushed the stage yeah like even my agent
his agent were like you know it's it's
gonna lead to other things and people
think it's the thing to do and like we
should up to secure
I wasn't worried about it I think they
what was smart though is like that they
do have some sort of security because
like you have to because you just got to
you just never know what could happen or
whatever and and I saw like in the
comedy club a guy grabbed the microphone
stand and tried to hit the comedian with
it and the [__] the bottom floor off it
hits the body that thing is kind of
dangerous I think it's about 20 pounds
right and so I think we should be
protected I think we shouldn't have to
worry about that [__] when we say we're
here to have fun man like you come in a
comedy club bro you don't need to bring
a gun or or be upset or whatever but you
know people get to drinking people get
offended or if everyone's laughing at
them they get in their feelings and [__]
but the funny thing about Dave was they
was like damn yeah yeah that dude took
off dude that's what I was gonna say
that dude that dude got bit
but I think he's preceded by Will Smith
so but I think it's good the media
showed what happened to that dude like
he got he got
it was good the new showed was like here
he is he was like in a wheelchair again
no that dude after everybody saw that it
stopped yeah because you know people
think oh it's sweet you can go up there
and try to tackle somebody but you don't
realize how many dudes back there I will
never forget
um
but this was just funny
uh they didn't know it was Katt Williams
he was in Philly
and I guess cat was just moving around
kind of like and cat jumped out on the
stage in Philly and the dudes jumped on
cat they wouldn't know they didn't know
it was Cash oh damn oh wow yeah it was
crazy and I'm like yo somebody was like
yo yo yo yo that's Cat Williams and they
was like what what oh [__] why are they
jumping just catch you little man
because he just ran out on the stage oh
and they thought he was they thought he
was like a civilian yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know um there's always
some little extra little something over
there you don't see it until you get
into it I feel like um I bet you will
Smith every single day like yeah every
day yeah because that that really did
make that really did do something we
didn't need that you know nobody no no
nobody you know
high side is 20 20. here
I voted for Will Smith for that Oscar he
put his foot in that role like he did
everything I mean he should have got an
Oscar a long time ago he was amazing
like what a perfect night right
hindsight is 20 20 like did that need to
happen that night hell no no you know
you wonder maybe you had a moment of
Madness truly like well
there's a lot of years of anger and
embarrassment I mean he was like I feel
like maybe maybe it's my night you're
gonna you're gonna play play play with
me on my night like maybe I'm not in the
mood for that it's my night I know that
I'm up for an Oscar yeah you know it
could be some of that what you're saying
but I say that's the situation for the
after party 100 so if Brian did
something to me and I wasn't feeling it
me and Brian gonna have a discussion at
after party I'm not good Brian is doing
his thing I
me and Brian we go over to the after
party I have an opportunity for me to
say how I felt about it he is an
opportunity apologize or not or blah
blah blah we are not supposed to display
that in front of the world like that's
just me I'm old school you know what I
mean I think that's most people though
bill but I mean the bummer is you're
talking about a Flawless career like
America's sweetheart that one thing man
it's yeah look at Dana White Dana White
Dana White yeah
smacked the living [__] out of his wife
right after she slapped him though and I
think that's the only reason he survived
that in a way and plus they've been
married forever but yes so it's a
one-two yeah I mean it depends how many
years people were like most people were
like I think two things happened with
that one is she slapped him he slapped
her got in this fight two they've been
married for 25 years they're still
married she came out and said stay out
of our business and I think with all
those things a lot of people went oh
that's that that's that deep entangled
marriage [__] that I don't want to stick
my foot into because I don't like that
was a moment between both of them where
they lost some human beings can forget
first I don't think I think it's more of
Dana like he's he's a fight promoter and
he's in that fight business it's a dark
world yeah you can't cancel anyways what
do you want me to do yeah yeah but I
think it was a combination like a you
can't cancel he's uncountable so all
right go ahead and bark doesn't matter
yep uh
the sponsors didn't do [__] what are you
gonna do but what my point where I
brought it up was if he could do it
again he probably wouldn't have right it
was in the moment yes supporting what
you said like yeah wife smacked the [__]
out of you like yo we had a party
yes go sit down yes like what the [__]
and I said I've seen that between I've
seen that in regular people like like
girl were you looking at her tits pow
yeah yeah you know yeah I mean Dana
followed up with the Kirby but that was
weird you know well I I remember my my
uh my Friday I had a witness to this too
my girl
she she got drunk and she I had a party
in my house
and she thought I was looking at this
before I knew where that was she thought
I was looking at a girl at the party
which I promised you I wasn't right for
once and uh like maybe I was I guarantee
but she decided she just decided she
decided
and she was tough I remember she swung a
boot at my head with the kind of
ferocity
hooker crook I ducked and it broke a
hole in my plaster wall
and my buddy saw it and then she jumped
on me and started me and what I ended up
doing is kind of pulling her off and I I
tried I tried to pull her into the room
so she didn't make a scene now if he if
I hadn't had a witness it would have
looked like I was dragging her in there
correct you didn't see what happens
thank God you had to win it I was like
oh you're you're drunk and crazy at this
point but you never know man [__] like
that how you react you better you you
it's hard that's what I'm saying like
those moments cell phones out everywhere
in those moments man it's just so hard
to I mean obviously we're here we think
about it and we go okay we wouldn't want
to do that I mean I'm at the Oscars why
would uh I want to have a fight tonight
you know I'm dressed nice when I'm with
my wife I'm having a good time and then
something crazy happens
man I hope that at some point he can
just be past it and just like I think he
will right you know what I mean I don't
know the questions they still bringing
up Chris Brown's thing that's almost 20
years ago damn near but they're always
competitive for some reason the larger
question is can he the real question is
can Will Smith and I think he will I
hope can he get over it like in a way
Chris Chris Rock came after him in such
an unbelievable way with that story so
yeah if you're gonna do that yeah and so
you there's a lot to live up to in that
sense in a lot of ways for him but he
doesn't have to he's never he's never
going to go Tit for Tat with Chris Rock
too dope projects put out a new movie
that blows us away and he will anyway
he's undeniable he's so [__] talented
bro bro he'll be fine you know he'll be
fine I mean I'm just a big Will Smith
fan you know what I'm saying I just like
I don't know anyone who's I always
always root for will you know what I
mean I felt like you know will really
did it the right way you know he he
worked hard and grinded it out and did
what he needed to do and you know we all
make mistakes but I just thought like to
me because I thought he was going to get
the Oscar for Ali I thought he did a
good job on that
um and uh uh this time you know uh you
know I have an opportunity to be in be
in the uh on the board for that yeah for
the Oscars I get a chance to vote so I
don't know you're on the board yeah man
that's that's pretty crazy from Jersey
yeah Jersey Boys just like baller up
there man I was like what
so so it was good because there were so
many great movies and stuff like that
I've always been a film guy like always
have you yeah I've always loved film
well always the top five most
influential films for you top five oh
you want it okay Godfather yep thank you
um Godfather
Shawshank Redemption damn good call so
far in my top five yeah uh good call uh
any give me Sunday I think it's the best
football movie ever ever it was the
program that you guys came along
um but that's another dumb one that is
like oh my God oh my God
um platoon
that's our generation remember
and Officer and a Gentleman oh my God
bro now you're now well this is our age
come on this is all right
sugar britches bro how about Louis
Gossett Jr in that murdered it what the
[__] happened Beast Mode God he's so
great yo that movie was crazy you know
what I'm saying George I'm too young for
it so yeah
I understand hey you gotta understand
that I'll check it out but George has no
[__] that movie's so good he's 20. so
good he's 24. yeah platoon is cold ain't
it my grandmother wants to fly Jets five
seconds in the platoon oh my God [__] oh
my gosh [__] dude an old-timey movie to
him is Friday oh yeah yeah Friday's
bombed but I'm talking about like a
movie
to you they changed it made you guys I'm
not going to war bro correct that [__]
is next left you it's stuck with you it
stuck with you forever
oh bro and he died like that question in
that Charlie Sheen yeah yeah now now now
um and I remember I never forgot this in
uh in
I forgot how many people's in there it's
unbelievable bro platoon what year was
it
1986 six I was three years old Johnny
Depp was in that Kevin are you serious I
don't know Johnny Depp was in platoon
yeah he played one I gotta watch it
again Keith David remember Keith David
Keith David I kind of I remember Lee
Tyson Henley was in that he was in Any
Given Sunday
wow William defoe's been in everything
Charlie Sheen was in here Tom Behringer
great actor that's right Kevin Dillon
baby yes he was super young yes he was
wow look at that cast man amazing that
movie right there is hard body though
officer and gentleman though I mean when
he's lying on the ground and he goes you
can forget it he goes it's all I got I
got nowhere else to go it's all I got it
was like it was the first time I was a
kid I looked at I was like that's
desperation yeah that's when you don't
have a left right a turn or a right turn
and you have no other options and you're
begging somebody for something
when you truly need somebody damn that's
a good movie yeah yeah that's a good
movie
you know you were a certain age or
whatever but like there's certain films
that just go wow you feel so deeply yeah
because something in the messaging
um hits home for you because you say to
yourself I gotta get my life together
yeah one beautiful things about
mythology and story is you you say to
yourself I can't live the way I'm living
right now I don't want to be ordinary no
I I I I I want to feel deeply Avatar do
that for me
not a bad mood smoke a lot of weed
that's not bad movies like yeah it's all
that actually sent me Avatar when I was
watching 3D I got a little taken in I
was like this is good
you got you got besides
uh Sean's definitely on their Godfather
I like Goodfellas up there I love Good
Fellas Sunny great movie no no good
feeling mine's mainly comedies though
like uh the classical ones like Ace
Ventura Friday was dope yeah but I'm
movies that made you feel deeply
because I like war movie [__] too that's
hard
Black Hawk Down was crazy wow black
heart down the the energy of that film I
auditioned for that movie that movie and
I'm gonna tell you another movie that's
better than that is heat oh bro I got
shot dead I just re-watched he have you
seen heat if yeah dude I'm America bro
what a classy you know where they're
sitting down
it's a true criminal like you can like
you believe reviews unbelievable must
outstanding there are certain movies
like that but another movie yes but to
be honest with you more recent that
really was a hard body movie was the
Revenant yes that's that yeah
yeah
what's your name Joy George is like yeah
you know the capital didn't even talk
you got yeah you got a lot I know the
stunt guy who I knew his stunt double
his stunt double and his stuff because
he was just some water all day just he
just said he froze and it was just crazy
but I mean that [__] was crazy dude
there's certain movies yeah wrestle he
had to wrestle that football player you
ever see that when the way they shot it
so the bear with the bear was a was a
football player bring this up he was a
giant football player who had to wear
all the uh The Furs and [__] no no uh
but also all the electronic stuff so
they could they could all like propose
you understand so he had to get he had
to wrestle with him and get [__] up
with him it's crazy the bear scene is
Bonkers oh it's is it this one right
here yeah yeah the bear see makes you
realize if he was in the woods and you
saw that bear you're done you screwed
yeah this guy yeah
oh my God yeah
it can't be that interesting the guys
upon the student kind of toss them
around yeah oh you're shooting in a yeah
so the blue
that's a good time
it's embarrassing for your kids right
Leonardo was if you're like hey I was in
the revenue
that movie was about survival man what
you gonna do man and make it man come on
based on I think Tom Hardy story that's
not real right no I mean I'm sure it
happens so he got attacked by a bear and
the way he survived apparently was he
could he could only crawl and he would
push he would set up a wall he'd set up
like this wall and then push like uh all
everything this way to get like rats and
grasshoppers everything he could eat in
against the wall and grab it and and
kill him it says Hugh glass existed he
did get attacked by a bear yeah
hear these stories about what it was
like the Native American sometimes would
catch you they'd kill everybody and then
they would just take one dude and they'd
cut the bottom of your feet off
take your boots cut the bottom of your
feet off and then just make you crawl
back to Native Americans were Savages
you'd have to crawl back and be like
well the term Savage comes from all
right they like scap each other and [__]
yeah they let you feel it oh yeah be
like what happened to you
human beings human beings thought of
lots of really artistic ways to to
Really punish you huh all human beings
medieval times they got creative with
them but
what's being removed the wheel to do
medieval on his head oh my God all right
that's another great movie
go get the gesture
back in the day we had a tough job being
the gesture oh yes because what if your
jokes didn't work kill him I'm not
laughing I'm not laughing I don't like
him hey what do you got chin
Uh current events current events yeah so
this is really current so let's talk
about this one first Conor McGregor he
was at a wake again yeah so he was at a
wake for his aunt his lady ante passed
away then afterwards he went to a pub in
Liverpool there was a huge yeah there's
a huge I think it's yeah I think
somewhere in London somewhere in the UK
okay and then um
there's this huge Rumble that happened
why does he always get in trouble yeah
there's so many different levels
security at this he did that's why I
don't understand but he had security and
he booked ad security though
I'll show you a little bit of this
Rumble here oh they did they show these
shows Connor fighting and see Connor
though that's the thing but you see
Connor leaving right away
now hold on I might be crazy here but
how do we know if a fist fight didn't
break out in this Pub and Connor's like
I don't be so sure with this let's get
the [__] out that's possible too yeah
people are just like Connor threw the
punch maybe or he's in a rough area of
[__] UK that's a good point he's like
man I won't be a socialist but he's one
of those guys that people try to 100
he's always yeah
it looks to me like he's trying to get
the hell out of there yeah but he booked
it right away but then so obviously
there's a jacket there there's rumors
swirling around that he was in the
bathroom for like 35 this is just from
people you know saying that they saw
this stuff yeah with someone's girl also
he was in the bathroom 35 minutes boning
some chick or whatever but there's been
the same narrative every time it's
getting old man but this is like there's
no evidence of anything so no there's
nothing it's all hearsay but Connor was
that a problem we went out in the
bathroom now like it's that fast what's
that oh yeah boning out with your chicks
real quick yeah
and then also this last thing he's
saying I've heard that about four times
I'm like that's what it's at now you
meet somebody and they don't wait they
don't go back man
yeah like he can't do nothing clean it's
got to be like thank you so much I love
all of you it's messy that gave me an
opportunity to fight here today [__] yo
[__] yeah oh like like he goes like it's
like he's got that he can be turned he's
got a square at his level how's someone
like you we ain't going to bars I was
gonna say it doesn't work I was gonna
say I know you have your whiskey no good
customer going out and hanging out with
a group here invite your boys to your
house we don't need to be dealing with
all this right that's right they know
but you just don't have a good team
around him yeah and he's paying out the
ass with these nothing good happens also
at night well that's during the day but
I hear you yeah see we sound like grown
men we do next we do
this woman used to be an escort and she
said that that you know the gilgore
murderer the Gilgo dude that just got
that serial killer in Long Island you
hear about this no he killed Four Women
then he he couldn't figure out who did
it it's ten years ago they just caught
his ass legit serial kill look at him
giant man too a giant eyes are way too
close together for me but either way
it's got nice serial killer what what
what okay I'm out tell me what's up so
they just caught him they found a bunch
of body parts strewn no bodies actually
body parts yes but body parts too he was
dismembering them and they were strewn
out and they couldn't find it but he
they knew he was sadistic because he
called the sister of one of the girls
and they were escorts and he taunted her
for a long time they would get off on
they couldn't catch him and they know
they find out owns an architecture and
consulting firm in Manhattan wealthy
Family Man kids wife the whole thing
this is a psych psycho serial killer
when she traveled his wife would travel
a lot so when she would travel
he would be up to his business now they
only know of four they think that I
think it's up to 10 or 15. how did they
kill us that way DNA they found uh his
sisters here on some of the bodies and
then his wife's hair and they suspected
he was a suspect so they want to see if
the DNA matched and he ate a pizza and
threw it away and they took the DNA from
the pizza got his ass Ten Years Later
got him off got him
Stanford Pizza Hut they don't give up
it's their raised Pizza Pizza the FBI
once it gets on let me see what she said
so she used to be an escort that I think
she went on a day with him she went on a
date with him and then uh so she said
that during the date he would say like
do you like True Crime like he was super
into it and then did you hear about the
Gilgo murders he was saying sounds like
10 years ago
so it's a long video but so
in a nutshell she said that and then
when she went on a date he said that or
she said that he said that he she felt
like he said other people were involved
like she knew other people were involved
like she doesn't think that he was the
only killer like he's protecting other
people nah oh man we should listen to
this escort yeah yeah she looks she
likes I'll play a little bit for you
guys it's three minutes long wait hey so
you all asked for my story time about my
day with Rex hewerman the Gilberto Beach
killer
I don't even know how to get into this
it's crazy to me so
let's just have at it so I don't really
know where to totally begin with this it
was anywhere from 2014 to 2016. part of
me thinks that I should go to the cops
and talk to them because he did say
information that like wasn't let out to
the public and honestly that's what made
me look the date because I knew because
I was watching videos and I was
following this case
so anyway uh we went we met at a place
in Port Jeff uh a seafood place and I
kind of had a bad feeling to begin with
but I don't always trust my God I was
young and dumb so I went we sat down we
had normal formal talk what do you do
what are your hobbies we had a drink
nothing big and then
he brought a true crime I was like are
you a true crime man and I was like
actually yeah I I could probably tell
you more about this long story huh yeah
who got shot anyway
Beach killer and I was like of course
everybody on Long Island does we're all
following in that case
um and he started saying things that
first of all led me to believe it was
not just him there were other people
involved uh he was taking the fall
though I think for all of them and I
think he would help because
you know he's a killer yeah they have a
he had his burner phones with the traces
they always act alone they're nuts I
mean that's what she said she's not even
she doesn't say that right and that date
sounds super boring strange angle she's
doing I don't know and also she he asked
her to go back to her place and then he
was like no don't take your car leave
your car here she's like I gotta I gotta
take my leave my car to restaurant so
she eventually was like no I'm not gonna
go to your place because he wanted to
take her in his car yeah he would have
killed her yeah she's about to be a
hologram yep yeah [__] good choice lady
bad people here's another word thing so
he this is him right here human he went
to the same high school I guess with
Alec Baldwin yeah Billy Baldwin down two
killers
awesome Long Island
let's kill her yeah damn everybody
killing us damn uh do you guys want to
talk about this real quick I don't want
to give this stupid girl credit oh he
was uh
like who who's offended
join us Hill X comes out she waits after
you have the baby you should know he was
so controlling I went through it and I'm
like oh dude just had bounce here go
back go back with me you see her she was
a surfer she's not though she's uh she's
an influencer well I'm saying she likes
to Surf yeah I like to play guides but
so what did you say and I liked flight
kites but like she posts this like like
is this supposed to cancel Jonah Hill
it sounded like did you just had
boundaries like can you not show your
ass in the pic you can you not hang out
with dudes and surf all the time and he
said if he can't then we're not supposed
to be like this isn't going to work he
was in like you have to do this he's
like here's my boundaries we don't [__]
with it let me know
she said this for her healing process
she has to do no it's these game more
followers I don't know anyone's siding
with her though God she's awful like a
little like can you just have some class
and keep it to yourself work it out
[__] oh you have to keep you have to
get put it out to the world for yourself
that's the problem that also it seems
like a nice guy and I'm not the right
partner for you if you can't do this
stuff and hopefully if these things
bring you a place of happiness I support
it no hard feelings but that's my bad
I'm a good guy man it seems pretty legit
great person yeah I don't want my girl
with her ass out what's the problem
that's like right down the middle yeah
terrible person
no he he's with another girl he just had
a baby and then she does this comes out
with it she has to be like she's trying
to get more followers get a surfboard or
some [__] sucks man come on Sierra there
you go Brady next the whitest one ever
what we got uh let's go with Cloud
chasing yeah man
uh this was a video of a U.S U.S soldier
trying to cross the boundaries into
North Korea while laughing why was he
trying to go North Korea oh that's smart
that's a great place
the onlookers thought at first it was
like a joke or like a tick tock or
something dumb bad tick tock idea yeah
apparently I don't know I think he's
just does he just get hemmed up [__] up
here
seems like things could go wrong over
there did I have a picture of him
running here is there a video North
Korea don't have a sense of humor oh I
guess there's no video
all right well so they take him out U.S
army soldier defected to Korea or North
Korea and yelled hahaha so I guess he
he wants to live in North Korea enjoy
that [__] well enjoy prison Dennis
Rodman over there for men tremendous
good place man they got nice beaches
Robin can get them out man yeah so
there's a flight that was supposed to go
from I think uh
a Vegas to Atlanta yeah right and then
so the it was just still on the tarmac
and they're saying there's something
there's some issues going on so just
stay if you leave the plane then you're
not going to get a flight out for
another like few days so you have to
stay on the tarmac people stayed on for
about four hours multiple people had to
get uh wheelchaired out yeah he wasn't
blasting yeah no ACG did you hear how
hot it was in the Persian Gulf at the
airport do you hear this what was it
150 degrees 152 degrees and that's
that's too hot for humans to be where in
the Persian Gulf right and right in uh I
think uh 150 oh man I was gonna go there
a lot of people
it's a major area but it's a major it's
a major there's nothing moving at 152 is
it you can't find the wheels right body
can't um regulate in that heat so you
you you animals die nothing can live
really I mean that's a that's at the
point where you can't the sweat doesn't
evaporate and you just I thought death
death value Death Valley was 130 yeah
150 degrees I think it's the hottest
ever recorded on planet Earth and that
was this past weekend all right that
global warming [__] is right so just to
put a button on this
um eventually the flight regardless we
couldn't go anyway so they had to leave
the plane and get rebooked the next day
the next day it was canceled again
I bet Delta game free peanuts the
customer service on airlines they don't
give hey [__] you're like I'm never
flying again oh my God you're not going
to Hawaii with your family okay here
what we're we're gonna do
we're gonna give you a 200 credit we're
gonna be a voucher for a few drinks yeah
thanks yeah we'll give you we'll give
you a couple of drinks and maybe a
Chick-fil-A gift card
well there's nothing to do either you're
like I'm never flying Delta they go cool
[__] we already got 10 other people
waiting it sucks
um yeah anyway this is 111 114 degrees
950 but that's still terrible 14 degrees
Yeah for hours well you see because when
I bring my comedy you know what I mean
so we talked about this on the last
episode what is going on with this
exactly it was fake well they still
don't know they're still investigating
it but they've like asked many people
have you seen a baby a toddler all the
drivers on the highway as many people as
possible no one saw any evidence of a
baby also they found in her car like she
went to a Target beforehand right to get
some snacks and then she went to a
restaurant to get food
and then when they checked the car there
was no more snacks or food but she left
her her iPhone watch or sorry the iWatch
and like her iPhone and her purse or
something it's very weird her parents
are saying that she got kidnapped and
then she had to fight for her life
yeah I don't know I think it's harder to
wear play stuff for snacks too that's
not really snacks that's right but it
won't stop in Target for just snacks
that thing's a nightmare dog you stop
that [__] the gas station bro yeah
7-11 Target commitment yeah there's one
right off the road I'll make you want to
make up a story like that there was like
a thing that there's a reward out for
you know people that could find her it
went up to like 68 000 that's the only
thing I could think of but I don't think
they made the uh the award thing the
reward thing I'm sorry reward look at
yeah yeah so I don't know what happened
what is this
um so this tennis player this is a
I don't know how important this match is
but she's like the 20 you know number 22
this Budapest person that's a lot so
she's yeah so this uh Chinese person is
world's number 22 and then she was tied
with this Hungarian player five five and
then I'll show you this real quick
so this her doing a serve and it hits
the line right
I thought it was good
so the commentators think it's good but
the Umpire said it wasn't good so she
said let's let's look at the line let's
see where it hit the thing it's a small
tournament
there's a stain right there and then
this is her opponent
she kicks off the smudge Mark so you
can't investigate anymore
[Applause]
before they come over before the
officials can come over the opponent did
the violation yeah damn well they do
they kill her
they tell that story gets exciting to
kill her they stump the [__] out
but uh so apparently she uh This Girl
retired minutes later with a panic
attack yeah she said she had some mental
issues or mental health before watch
Tennis now they have like a a light yeah
like a thing yeah I think that's like
the upper levels of this house I don't
think they have that Budapest yeah but
like yeah there's plenty of tennis stars
that are uh condemning that other player
for kids because that's like such a
[__] that's Poor's another girl
retired it's kind of I mean
chips she's kind of like what happened
right there's no longer there's no rule
right yeah
um so this is just a we already know
that Francis ingano is fighting Tyson
Fury in a boxing match but then
apparently there's a rematch clause only
if Tyson fear oh sorry yeah only if
Tyson Fury loses loses yeah uh Francis
is still up in the air yeah yeah
and that was on airline should be though
well bill
great what's good man
we did very well hey people talk tennis
they like tennis
you know you guys I like I like that you
know they caught the guy
the serial killer hell yeah we don't
need Siri covers out here no it's crazy
there's 66 active ones right now man
active active getting busy that's what
they're getting busy that's what they
say but we don't give them cool names
anymore and they're always normal like
surprisingly regular man well he lived
with his mom he was really quiet he kept
to himself it's always he never bothered
anybody there's a trailer of a movie you
can't promote he's on love song I'm
allowed to promote it am I or maybe not
how good was Wesley Snipes in the Kevin
Hart series on Netflix oh my God oh my
God
he was so scared he was good true story
that was a great yo that was a he's good
Wesley's nice how that didn't get more
attention I have no questions he's cool
as [__] too right told me which is a
bizarre
bizarre fact
his character blade save Marvel
real Marvel was Marvel was on the way
down especially at that time yeah hell
yeah Marvel was on their way down and
they didn't know that the blade would
work
blade pulled Marvel
out the ground to what it is now man wow
I didn't even know if uh blade was a
Marvel comic yeah did you know me I
didn't know I didn't know it was a
Marvel character he spent three years in
jail or something right is that how long
I think he yeah I think he liked it too
yeah that's a long time yeah and he paid
any pain he still had to go to jail and
he's but he's got money now I hope yeah
yeah he's cool he's what I'm saying like
he said he's a good guy man you know
he's like dude I paid him they knew what
was going on but they they just wanted
to make an example
now Wesley's a guy who came up through
he came up through the New York acting
program like he's a trained thespian
real deal like he can dance such a good
actor martial art To Wong Foo he's he's
got it all
so what do you guys do now after now you
guys I go home yeah go work out and then
I go home yeah what kind of workout
you're doing I do a 20 minute thing with
a 65 year old strong man you know in a
parking lot okay it's just body
maintenance so what he just throws you
around
no yeah I would do some white rice a
little oil I just do different like
circuit stuff someone that'll do
deadlifts pull-ups dips whatever it
might be I never know it sucks it's a
tough 20 minutes it's only 20. yeah but
it's a [__] like you look jacked it's
working no but it but that's that's it
that's it even if you wanted to put on
muscle and really get serious he'd work
you out 20 minutes 25 minutes but the
way he does it you you it's like that
CrossFit stuff but he doesn't believe in
Crossfit because you get injured but
right like the way he does it is is
um Bill you're in August you're in uh
Denver Improv Comedy theater where's
that at in Denver uh you know August
where am I now where is it because
you're in helium St Louis helium coming
up July 27th through the 29th Improv
Denver Denver Improv Comedy theater no
yeah they yeah it's a new one it's a
Denver Improv yeah because they got you
know the other one they have is called
comedy work yeah I just did that yeah do
Comedy Works I haven't done I haven't
done Comedy Works in about 10 years I
did it when I was on the last time I did
it I was hosting last common standard I
think damn yeah I think that was 2017.
so you're doing a theater that's the
theater yeah yeah that's a common
feature I got a couple theaters in there
like um
go downtown
so that that's August
um September and October I got some
theaters in there I love it man I'm
doing that I'm loving that peacock
theater here
I'm gonna be there uh August 3rd fourth
fifth
excited that's a nice room um Levity
Live yes it is I've never done it unless
yeah you're like it's just beautiful the
way they got it set up is really nice
I've heard your things uh Columbus is
set up nice yep yep on Columbus yeah I'm
there in August
I just did that's a really nice room
that you guys would like um
Milwaukee
oh wow hey bro bro
it's been it's been almost two years now
since they reopened it oh it's great
yeah it's great oh it might be the best
impact did you open that club yeah okay
because I was right behind you so it's
been it's one of the first ones but that
club is dope dope
yeah I walked down like in Milwaukee
what do we do
so this right here is a big show October
8th oh that Atlantic City Comedy
Festival Bruce Bruce Savage Crawford
Savage you go from South Carolina to
Philly bro I don't know how I'm gonna do
that all that travel that's a big
do you get tired of the travel because I
do yeah but not like I like I try to
take off a little bit like
you done you done with us
you done yeah yeah it's over oh it's
over all right yeah sign out or no yeah
oh yeah we're done Bill Bellamy
everybody ladies and gentlemen go see
him you're the best man
that's my time
you walk off like Biden